lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
empezar a explorar el concepto de la
entropía la primera vez que te exponen a
la idea de entropía parece un concepto
un poco misterioso pero a medida que
hagamos más vídeos espero que podamos
construir un sólido entendimiento de lo
que es muchas de las definiciones que
encontrarás de entropía van a contener
la palabra desorden por lo que podría
ser considerado como el desorden de un
sistema
ahora con solo esa definición en tu
mente te invito a que pausa este vídeo
ya que compares este sistema con este
sistema
quiero que compares esta habitación con
esta habitación y te preguntes cuál de
ellas tiene más entropía y luego quiero
que compares la luna con el sol y estas
imágenes claramente no están a escala si
los dibuja la escala el sol sería mucho
más grande pero cuál de estos sistemas
tienen más entropía
muy bien estoy suponiendo que ya pausa
hasta el vídeo e hiciste el ejercicio
cuando nos fijamos en estas habitaciones
podríamos decir que esta de aquí se ve
ordenada es una habitación limpia y
estaré aquí se ve desordenada es una
habitación desarreglada así que si todo
lo que tienes es esta definición podrías
decir bueno tal vez estas se encuentran
más desordenadas y puede que tenga más
entropía y no serías el único que piense
esto de hecho en un montón de libros de
texto usan esta analogía de una
habitación limpia y una habitación
desaseada en la que la habitación
desaseada tiene más entropía pero este
no es exactamente el caso este tipo de
desorden no es igual a este tipo de
desorden así que permítanme hacer esto
muy muy claro algo que está desarreglado
o desaseado o desaliñado no es igual a
entropía
para pensar en lo que significa el
desorden en el sentido de la entropía
vamos a tener que flexibilizar nuestra
perspectiva un poco más pero espero que
todo quede claro el tipo de desorden al
que se refiere la entropía es más el
número de estados que un sistema puede
asumir que quiero decir por los estados
de un sistema bueno si tengo un
contenedor como este y si tengo cuatro
moléculas que están rebotando así que
tengo esta molécula magenta
y tengo esta molécula azul y tengo esta
molécula amarilla por aquí
y luego tengo una molécula verde
este sería un estado en particular una
configuración en particular pero este
sistema podría asumir otras
configuraciones o podría tener otros
estados tal vez esta molécula amarilla
ahora está por aquí rebotaron hasta que
la molécula amarilla llegó aquí y la
molécula azul llegó hasta aquí tal vez
la molécula de color rosa ha terminado
aquí
y la molécula verde ahora está aquí por
lo que un sistema puede tener un montón
de estados diferentes aquí solo dibuje
dos estados para este sistema pero
podría haber muchos muchos más estados
para este sistema así que cada uno de
estos son un estado en particular para
el sistema imaginen este sistema en el
que tengo esta caja con las cuatro
moléculas dentro y vamos a compararlo
con otro sistema donde tengo una caja
más grande y vamos a decir que tiene más
moléculas vamos a decir que tiene dos
moléculas de color amarillo
y que tiene una molécula azul por aquí
una molécula verde
una molécula magenta
y una molécula color rosa claro por aquí
este sistema es más grande hay más
lugares en los que las moléculas pueden
estar y tienen más moléculas este
sistema puede asumir más configuraciones
o más estados solo he dibujado uno de
ellos pero hay muchos más si te imaginas
que estas moléculas están rebotando por
todos lados de diferentes maneras hay
muchos muchos estados diferentes que
podría asumir el sistema así que este
sistema sin que sepamos lo que las
moléculas están haciendo en determinado
momento podríamos decir que tiene más
estados posibles en relación con este
sistema este tiene un menor número de
estados posibles menos
estados
posibles
y debido a que este sistema de aquí
tiene más estados posibles más
configuraciones necesitaría decirte más
detalles para saber exactamente dónde
está todo diríamos que esto tiene más
entropía más
entropía
así que cuando hablamos de desorden en
realidad estamos hablando del número de
estados que algo podría tener y tiene
sentido que en este sistema en el que
hay muchas más cosas moviéndose en
muchas direcciones diferentes y que
tienen mucho más espacio para moverse
tiene sentido que el sistema en su
conjunto tenga mayor entropía así que
cuando hablamos de entropía no estamos
hablando acerca de cualquiera de los
estados específicos cualquiera de las
configuraciones específicas estamos
hablando del sistema en su conjunto sin
saber exactamente dónde se encuentran
las moléculas en este ejemplo con las
habitaciones solo estamos hablando de
estados particulares o estados
específicos desaseada es un estado en
particular limpia es un estado en
particular pero no estamos hablando del
número de configuraciones que una
habitación podría tener
de hecho si esta habitación es más
grande esta habitación en realidad
podría tener más configuraciones y si
estamos hablando a un nivel molecular si
esta habitación es calidad y esta
habitación es fría y de hecho si esta
habitación es más grande va a tener más
moléculas y esas moléculas van a tener
muchísimas configuraciones posibles por
lo que se podría debatir que ésta en
realidad tiene una entropía mayor
usando ese mismo razonamiento volvamos a
la comparación de la luna con el sol
cuál de éstos tienen más entropía bueno
vamos a pensar en ello el sol es más
grande tiene muchas muchas más moléculas
y esas moléculas se mueven de forma más
rápida y están más calientes y se están
moviendo hacia todos lados mientras que
la luna es pequeña es fría
tiene menos moléculas es en su mayor
parte rígida no tiene una temperatura
muy alta por lo que sus moléculas no
tienen mucho movimiento por lo tanto
tiene un número mucho menor de estados
tiene muchas menos configuraciones que
el sol la entropía del sol si la vemos
como un sistema si vemos al sol como un
sistema su entropía es mucho más alta
que la de la luna
entropía
mucho mayor
mucho mayor piensa en ello piensa en la
cantidad de información que necesitarías
para describir un estado de este sistema
necesitarías mucha información si
alguien quisiera decirte dónde está cada
molécula o cada átomo de la luna pero
necesitarías aún más información para
saber dónde está cada átomo o cada
molécula en un momento determinado en el
sol el sol tiene todas estas moléculas
moviéndose con tanta energía en este
volumen enorme
así que espero que esto empiece a darte
una noción de lo que es la entropía y
podrías decir bueno esto es solo una
discusión intelectual porque tanto
alboroto pues esto es importante porque
hasta cierto punto se puede describir el
universo en términos de entropía como
aprendimos en la segunda ley de la
termodinámica la entropía en el universo
está en constante aumento estamos
avanzando constantemente hacia un
universo con más estados posibles y esto
tiene todo tipo de implicaciones
interesantes